one of my initial interviews many many
years ago like they're writing my first
time management book I had interviewed
somebody about a totally you know
different thing related to her business
at one point and you know offhand she
mentioned her like six children and I
was like oh well that's interesting I
was you know very new and the parenting
journey so she's like oh my god how do
you do that so I called her back to
interview her about that she was running
a successful small business with many
people on the payroll and then also
raising her family and you know I passed
or well like spill your secrets like oh
the world would love to know and she
said you know everything I do is my
choice and rather than say I don't have
time to do X Y or Z she'd say I don't do
X Y or Z because it's not a priority
that I don't have time really means it's
not a priority and if you think about it
that is more accurate language I mean
people will tell you they don't have
time to floss it's not true they don't
want to floss you know using this
language reminds us that time is a
choice and so if you just substitute
this language every time you find
yourself saying I don't have time I
don't have time I'm too busy I don't
have time say it's not a priority and
and see how that feels
I'm joined by Laura van de Kamp today
and we are talking all things time Laura
welcome to the show thank you so much
for having me it's a pleasure to have
you on I've absolutely loved off the
clock which is your most recent book and
I've pounded through it over the last
couple of weeks not just because we're
about to do this podcast but also
because it was a genuinely fantastic
read so congratulations on an amazing
book thank you so much I really
appreciate that
so yeah we're talking about time and
time management so to begin with why is
time such a difficult task for people to
grapple with why is it why is it so
important for people to grapple with
yeah well there's a couple things going
on there I mean one of the reasons time
is so challenging for people is that it
keeps passing whether you think about
how you're spending it or not so it's so
easy to spend mindlessly you know
whether you make a decision about how
you spend today or don't make a decision
eventually we're going to be on the
other side of today so it requires you
to really think about it in a way that a
lot of other choices are more automatic
to make a conscious choice about but the
hopeful thing about time and in my
opinion at least is that we all have the
same amount of it so you know a life is
lived in hours and so what we do with
our lives is gonna be a function of how
we spend our hours and we all have the
same number of hours and we all have 24
hours in a day 168 hours in a week and
so when you find people who are doing
amazing awesome things in their lives
they may have many other things going
for them I'm not saying that they're not
rich or smarter better-looking than the
rest of us but they don't have more time
and so maybe we can look at how they're
allocating their hours and at least
that's something that we can pick up on
even if we can't copy all the other
things that you're doing you're totally
right the fact that we I have the same
number of hours in my day as Elon Musk
does is well I mean that's unless you
believe that he's actually much like
clone himself I've seen some people send
me mugs sometimes they say like you have
the same number of hours
is Beyonce which you know I'm not she
has many other things that she can
leverage to use those hours but I'm
guessing that she still wants to you
know do certain things in her
professional life that only she can do
and so she has to figure out how to do
that she probably wants to spend time
with her family which is also something
that she has to personally do even if
she has support on the home front as
well you know nobody can exercise for
her for instance that's something that's
actually impossible to outsource however
rich and famous you are and and so you
know how does she allocate her hours I
mean I may not be able to afford all the
things Beyonce does but I could learn
something from from how she spends her
time one of the things that you've
touched on there that's that I always
talk to my friends about is Conor
McGregor so Conor McGregor unbelievable
talent right in mixed martial arts and
now he's a businessman and he's doing
all this other stuff but he's just
recently had a kid and like Darius
could've been a time at 3:00 in the
morning when Conor McGregor's had to
change a dirty nappy like that's that's
happened 100% and there's a quote from
Erasmus it's actually in the school of
life confidence book which is like 70
pages big and it says from the king and
his castle to the peasant in the street
everybody shits true the fact that you
write there's certain things so as we
get into the book I'm sure people
understand what we mean but I saw Cal
Newport is a big proponent of your book
which is like I mean he's one of the one
of my favorites thinkers and one of my
favorite books of this year I
interviewed in earlier on and to talk
about systems and improving your
processes and outsourcing things it's
great but you're totally right there's a
lot of things that only you can do so
where do we start we're looking at our
168 hours in a week or 24 hours in a day
how do we begin to get a better grasp on
just what's happening well one of the
best things you can do is actually
figure out where your time is going so I
am one of these crazy people who tracks
my time I've actually been doing this
for four years now which nobody else
needs to do but I do recommend trying to
track your time for a week because a
week tends to be the cycle of life as we
actually live it you know if you track a
week you will see this is pretty much
what my life look
like and you know everyone who does this
gets something from it
very few people are completely and
totally aware of where all hundred sixty
eight hours of their week go we have
various stories we tell ourselves but
many of those stories are based on how
we feel about our time you know if we're
tired if somebody is you know stressing
us out if you know a particular week has
had a lot of one thing or another you
know these are all things that influence
our perception of where the time goes
but when we actually keep track of it we
may get very different impressions and
so I think it's important to work from
good data same thing if you were trying
to make a business decision you'd want
reliable data so that you knew you were
changing the right thing and exactly the
same with time I mean maybe something
you thought was a problem really isn't
maybe something you never even
considered is taking far more time than
you might have imagined so you track
your time in half-hour increments right
from like is it 5:00 in the morning
until 4:30 in the morning yeah you're
good fun spreadsheets if I've allowed to
use those two words together that have
the days of the week across the tops and
Monday through Sunday and half hour
blocks down the left-hand side from 5:00
a.m. to 4:30 a.m. if any of your
listeners want to go to my website you
can get a copy but you can also just
make it yourself because I promise it is
very low-key Excel type stuff this you
could whip this out in like 50 seconds
if you wanted um but I just write down
what I'm doing a couple times a day I
tend to check in like 3 to 4 times a day
based on sort of how full the day is it
usually takes me about a minute each
time so this really only takes me 3
minutes or so per day same amount of
time I spend you know brushing my teeth
or something which is it's just not that
big a chunk of time and it's so useful
you know because I truly know where my
time goes like I can't tell myself I'm
working 80 hours a week or something
like that because I'm clearly not like I
can see that I have
that I sleep on average it's somewhere
between seven point three and seven
point four hours per day when you
average it over you know usually a
period of about three or four weeks
that's where it will come out too I
spend about an hour a day in my car
which is not something I would have
thought because I don't tend to drive
long distances like I don't have a daily
commute so I in my mind I was spending
zero at a time in my car but of course
that's not true when I added up it was
it was far more significant that I might
have thought so you know you just want
to see where the time goes and then you
can decide do I like it which if so
awesome if you are unhappy about
anything if you'd like to do more of
something or if you'd like to do less of
something well then now you know what
the numbers are and so then you can
start working from there yeah I think
time is this kind of ephemeral nebulous
difficult to define experience that we
all go through and without the hard data
to actually look at where you're
spending your time you told you right
it's open to interpretation a lot like
when someone looks in the mirror they
may have lost 4 pounds but if they're
having a bit of a bad day and they're in
a bit of a mood
they might wake up and look at
themselves in there and think I look
terrible today anyway well by every
quantifiable metric you're better but
you're allowing your own subjective
interpretations to to kind of get away
with themselves so you studied a number
of people who were tracking their time
and some were good and some were bad
can you explain some of the
characteristics of people who had good
was it time mindfulness what was the
term sure time mindfulness is certainly
something you could you could say um you
know I've done a number of different
time diary projects every years there
was the one for off the clock I did a
different one for a book I wrote called
I know how she does it
but one of the things that's key for
people who are visibly using time well
is that they are intentional about their
time and so you can see things like if
somebody gets up in the morning and
exercises well that didn't happen
randomly it's like you don't just like
you know magically wake up at like 5:45
and think I'd like to go for a run like
that you know this is somebody who's
thought about like this is the best time
of my day to do exercise so this is what
I'm gonna make it happen
or somebody who starts Monday morning
with a focused work project like they
had to think about that they had to look
at their week ahead of time and say well
this is something I would like to get
done this week I'm gonna start Monday
with it because that's probably when I
have the most energy like most people
don't show up at work Monday morning be
like oh yeah now that I should do this
project like people who don't think
about it spend the first part of Monday
like you know answering emails and then
walking around the office see what's
going on you start then whatever their
first meetings 10:30 or something and
then the the mornings kind of gone but
if they thought about it maybe they use
8:30 to 10:30 for that project before
they go to that 10:30 meeting so you can
really see things like this and and off
the clock one of the most interesting
things I discovered about people who
were spending time well is that they
were highly likely to spend I had people
track in March Monday so a very ordinary
day like nothing nothing special about
this day whatsoever um but the people
who had the most abundant perspective on
time who really felt like time was sort
of most working in their favor who felt
relaxed about it we're highly likely to
have done something very interesting
during their leisure hours on that March
Monday so I mean I there was somebody in
my study who went like to salsa dancing
lessons on a Monday night somebody went
to a big band concert like somebody went
to a movie with their family and kind of
Monday night or you just little it could
be little things like a trip to the
playground with a family on a Monday
night but just something that wasn't
like get home from work eat dinner watch
TV all go to bed
like they'd actually thought about it
and what might be fun and they did it
and that made them feel like they had
more time when it comes to planning in
advance and structuring your days I I
can't help but think about Cal Newport
deep work and James clears atomic habits
the fact that segmenting off time to do
to go deep as Cal calls it on one
particular task is a lot easier than
being bounced around between multiple
different tasks and kind of getting rag
dabao by whatever the next thing that
appears in consciousness is and then as
James says you don't rise to the level
of your goals you fall to the level of
your systems and having those systems in
a
definitely appears to give people more
liberation with their time so one of the
best that chapter 2 for me was was my
favorite chapter in the whole book and
the main question that I had going into
that was why does time appear to go
faster as we get older would you be able
to tell the listeners why that is yeah
so I mean time passes at the same rate
regardless but most people have this
impression that time has sped up but if
they think back to when they were a kid
like oh you know summer lasts forever
you know they have all these memories of
their youth but like last year seems to
have gone quite quickly or what often
happens is you see like a child that you
haven't seen in a while and you're like
wow look at how much you've grown it's
because you know the time since you last
saw this kid did not fill the cognitive
space of like two years in your mind and
so you're like whoa but what's happening
is that time our perception of how much
time we have had is shaped by how many
memories we have of any given unit of
time so when we say you know where did
the time go
what we're actually saying is that I
don't remember where the time went
and that's because we haven't done
anything memorable with it so much of
adult life tends to get into these sort
of routines and routines are great they
help make good choices automatic but if
it's not a routine to necessarily make
something good happen it's just routine
because that's what your life looks like
and you never think about it you do it
over and over again then no day stands
out in your mind like there's no reason
for you to remember any given day if no
day is different from another then you
won't remember it and when you have no
memories of time it disappears so the
way to counter this is to ask yourself
the question of why is today different
from other days and it's a version of
the Passover question you know you ask
on the night of Passover the why is
tonight different from all other nights
and of course with Passover there's a
very specific reason it's a holiday it's
a major holiday you're celebrating that
but it's a good question to ask in a
secular context to which is that like
you know why should I remember today
like what did i do today that will stand
out in my memory and
saying that you'll be able to answer
that for all the days of your life and
it was probably unrealistic but if you
could answer it for more of them then
you will have more memories of time and
then time will start to feel more sort
of thick and rich I guess that the image
I used in the book is it will be like
this rich tapestry as opposed to a slick
linoleum floor yeah it was a good
analogy the sentence that you put in
which was the days are forgettable and
therefore we forget them that kind of
really struck home to me I was like well
yeah of course like why why would I
remember a day where I've done the same
thing over and over would you be able to
explain about the car journey analogy to
work I really enjoyed how that well so I
mean one of the things people do over
and over again is commute to work and if
you have spent let's say four years at
the same job and you drive the exact
same way to work every single morning
like this hour each morning is you know
been a thousand hours over four years
but you know in your mind it's just one
journey like there's nothing different
about each one of them so a thousand
years I mean a thousand hours becomes
one hour right like that's what it can
compress down to and you know with
something like that I mean the analogy
isn't perfect because of course what are
you gonna do about that like you have to
commute to work like you're not gonna
drive some incredibly different way and
if you've got an hour long drive you
can't do anything else so you're not
gonna bike that early because then it'd
be three times as long but you know it's
just something to think about like if
there are certain chunks of your days
that have to be the same then you need
to be very cognizant of the times that
you can make something different like so
can you you know go talk to someone new
at lunch or go somewhere different or
you know seek out new projects at work
can you do interesting things in your
personal life with your family types and
on the weekends can you think about you
know planning weekend's adventures into
your life or you know maybe take that
salsa dancing lesson on a Monday night
or something but think about the parts
of your life that you can do different
things and can switch up the routine a
little bit because there's a lot of
parts of life that you may not be able
to do that as much yeah is novelty the
only way that you can look too
spend time you can also make it expand
by making it sort of deeper and more
intense you know one of the reasons that
we remember say high school or college
better than like a random three four
years of adult life is that there were
so many intense experiences for most
people during this time it may be it was
their first job first love like first
time driving a car you know whatever it
is there's things you're gonna remember
because they were intense um and and so
you know you can think about how can I
do more intense things now like how can
I do things that maybe seem scary a
little bit outside my comfort zone but
we'll definitely be memorable you know
whether it's like giving a speech like
maybe that's something that you know if
you don't do a lot of it you'll remember
it because it's gonna be an intense
experience or you know anything along
those lines much travel there's the
novelty but there's also the intensity
of the experience and these are the
things that make it expand in memory
that's definitely I'm sure all of the
listeners at home will know what we're
talking about when you say that you go
away on holiday and you can remember
like I went to Africa in November and I
remember the the book that the guy
reception who'd booked us into our first
hotel stay out of like 20 nights I
remember the book that he had in his
hand this ornithology book about birds
and I remember his name and I remember
like the kind of shoes that you had on
as we walked to I'm like if you asked me
anything about my commute to work this
morning I couldn't tell you I couldn't
tell you what time I left probably I
wouldn't be able to tell you anything at
all but you're totally right the novelty
plus intensity I guess when you kind of
combine them together you got novelty
and intensity working in in
synchronicity but it really steps things
up and yeah that's why holidays feel
they strike so many cords right yeah and
what it is is that your brain has no
idea what its gonna need to remember in
the future and so it's remembering all
of it like you didn't know if this guy
booking you into the hotel is going to
play a major role in your life you know
I don't know if the your you know game
preserve and maybe the Lions will attack
you need to know him right like it that
your brain has
idea so it's holding on to all of it
whereas you know most of life your
commute is your commute like you don't
need to remember it there was nothing
new about it there was nothing that
you're already sure it's safe because
you've done it a thousand times so you
don't remember any of it so it's yeah
that's that novelty and that intensity
combined together can make there's also
an interesting I forget where I read
this but um that the brain has a natural
rate of remembering of something like
six to nine events per fortnight you
know and and so the thing is that if you
have a bunch of novel experiences which
you would on the first day of vacation
like you could have six new experiences
before breakfast right and so that's why
it seems like it's a hugely long day at
the beginning of the vacation is because
you're packing so much new stuff in you
totally right again this centered sorry
to start keep quoting your own content
back to you but the sentence of people
say they want more time what they really
want is more memories that to me just it
was such a such an eye-opener Gretchen
Rubin talks about something similar I
think she says she actually does suggest
taking a different route to work every
so often
which if you live in a city like myself
might be a absolute nightmare if I go
down the wrong Street and I go by road
and that will be a both novel and
intense experience when a rocket blade
to a meeting but yeah I totally get it
would you be able to talk about the past
present and future self yes this is
another part of um how we experience
time and and why we don't necessarily
make life memorable so there's been some
interesting work like Daniel Kahneman
writes about the remembering self and
the the present self and so I you know
through it another one is like the
anticipating self that anyway our story
like what your brain thinks about
there's the here and now but a lot of
your brain is also looking at other
points in time it's remembering stuff
you did in the past so that's the
remembering self or it's looking forward
to stuff you're gonna do in the future
so that's the anticipating self and what
winds up happening is that we give way
too much attention to how we feel in the
present even though our life's too
really depends on both the past and the
future as well and so what winds up
happening is you know we say like oh I'd
like to do great awesome things in my
life I'd like to do interesting things
you know I'd like to go to that salsa
dancing lesson on Monday night then you
get home from work on Monday night and
you are tired right and you feel like
well you know I could do salsa some
other time I mean the TV's right here
you know I've worked hard
let me just kick up my feet maybe some
other time you know but what's happening
um this one philosopher Robert greed and
I quote is he says we pamper the present
like a spoiled child I sort of give in
to its whims to do nothing but when you
constantly do nothing well then you have
nothing memorable I mean watching the TV
is not a memorable way to spend the
night going to the salsa dancing lessons
probably is so what we need to do is
make sure we are taking into account
both the anticipating and the
remembering self in addition to the
present self so if you're anticipating
self thought it would be really fun to
do something like probably you
remembering self will also be glad to
have done it so think about that and not
just how you feel right now if you can
tell yourself you know this I'm trying
to you know I've got one actor trying to
be a give a monologue and what should
really be a three actor play like
sometimes that can nudge you to just
plan it in and then do it anyway because
once you start doing it you will
probably draw energy from the fact that
it's fun and enjoyable and meaningful
and then afterwards you're gonna be glad
you did it I mean one way or another
this evening will be over like
eventually you will get into bed tonight
and it could be getting into bed having
had a really cool time it salsa dancing
lessons or it can be getting into bed
having just watch TV like you did the
past seven nights in a row so you know
think about it I think that's a really
really powerful concept I was talking to
a friend about this recently to do with
training we were talking about the fact
that if you've got if we're doing
intervals let's say in the gym and
you've got another two or three
intervals left the voice in the back of
your head that says I'm tired this is
stupid this sucks I've already done most
of the work I kinda don't need to do
anymore
I might injure myself even though you
know you don't you're not gonna injure
yourself like all of the things the
present self
is kind of like water cutting through
rock like it's always going to try and
take the easiest route and yeah the time
is going to pass anyway the fact that
the time is going to pass no matter what
you do means that you might as well do
it doing something that you're
remembering self in the future is going
to feel good about because right now the
present is transient but the future is
forever and the fact that there's an
asymmetry with that means that I think
so many so many choices would be better
made if people thought before they were
about to do something tomorrow
how am I gonna feel about this decision
that I'm about to make yeah yeah am I
gonna eat the cookie or am I gonna have
a banana or an apple am I gonna go to
salsa dancing or am I just gonna sit on
the couch and watch Netflix and we're
gonna do another round of this
particular workout which is again the
time is going to pass in any case the
only that you get what you're gonna do
you go pick your phone up from your bag
check your phone and do do some
Instagram or whatever and then you let
well before that I'm in the car and I
could have I could have finished that
off and had the extra sense of
satisfaction in retrospect ya know I
mean that's exciting if you think that
you will have been happy to have done it
then just do your future self a favor
and go ahead and do it I get it I'm
touching on the holidays thing again as
well I remember a Tim Ferriss article
quite a while ago where he said that he
books like up to six holidays at once
but he'll book them for like 20 22 20 24
and he'll have all of these things and
what he talks about with that is that
your equivalent of the anticipating self
gets pleasure from the holiday there is
so much greater than the amount of time
that they're at the holiday for so you
can go away for a week but if you've
booked a holiday two years in advance
you get excited for two years for a one
which is pretty cool right what a way to
stretch the pleasure and and there's
been some interesting research into this
people are happiest about it vacation
before the actual vacation because it
turns out that we're sort of incapable
of complete bliss in the moment like you
can be sitting on a tropical beach you
know watching a gorgeous
sunset like the love of your life beside
you and be thinking like my toe itches
like I mean this is the reality of our
physical bodies and just the way our
brains work but you in your anticipation
you're not thinking about your til
itching I mean that's just not something
that comes up so you and your
anticipation you're thinking about the
tropical beach and and the you know
drink and the sunset and all that stuff
so yeah max out your pleasure by
anticipating it as long as possible I
guess as well by committing to making
plans in advance what we're actually
going to be able to do is not only
satisfy the anticipating self hopefully
make a commitment that bypasses the
present self who can sometimes be a dick
and then the remembering self will be
gratified by it but also in the build-up
to that you have all of this extra
pleasure as well so the experiencing
self or the present self also gets that
stretched I think that's that whole
concept I really hope that the listeners
at home take this to heart because it's
something that's kind of been floating
around in different different pieces
some of qaol Newports work and some of
James clears working some of Gretchen
Rubens working but I'd never had it
delivered to me kind of in one-one
succinct message before and it was it
was very very useful so I really hope
that that everyone takes our on board
moving on what were some of the other
tools that people can use to help expand
their sensation of time or also help
them become more mindful of their time
well one tool that I found fascinating
is this idea of learning to savor time
which is to know that you are enjoying
something and acknowledge that you are
enjoying something and you know times
when we're not enjoying ourself when we
run happy when we're uncomfortable they
naturally slow down you know we've come
very aware of time in these situations
but I mean wouldn't it be awesome if you
could make the good time sort of passes
slowly as these bad times and one of the
ways you can is really calling attention
to it like you know pause and be like
hey I'm having a really good time right
now
and I mean that sounds a little crazy
but like why not like tell the people
you're around like I'm really enjoying
myself right now
oh you're enjoying yourself to this
what is cool that's going on oh the
music is great like the scenery is
awesome these people are so fun you know
and just anything you can think of to
sort of articulate and lock in the
memory um and one of the scenes I quote
is a man who doesn't inclined me one of
the researchers into this topic of
savoring is also a very serious mountain
climber and he'd talked about you know
and he's summiting a mountain he really
tried to stretch out the time when he's
on the summit like think about
everything you can lock in anything you
can see that you can then describe to
yourself and keep that memory or you
know who's here with you what does this
person look like what are we saying to
each other you know pause and take it
all in how are you feeling think back to
a time when you didn't have this and now
you do so you can really relish that
pleasure and when you do these things
you manage to stretch it out I mean
nothing lasts forever of course this is
the nature of time but when you can
really make that memory strong then
those say 10 minutes of being at the
summit of a mountain can become much
bigger in your mind then you know 10
minutes while you're making breakfast in
the morning yeah yeah I couldn't agree
more how do you how do you mediate
between the fact that we're often told
that we need to be present and we need
to focus on what's happening right now
with the fact that we need to be kind of
meta cognizant of things and we almost
need to observe the observer a little
bit and then we also need to anticipate
and then we need to remember like it it
feels like the common narrative about
focusing on being present kind of works
a little bit bit of contradictory unis
to that would you agree yeah I don't
think it's really a paradox I mean I
think that we can be enjoying the moment
but part of our enjoying the moment
being present in the moment is in two
it's really thinking about where it
stands in relation to our past in our
future one of the things that lends
significance to a moment is thinking
about yourself in the future looking
back on this you know if you can picture
yourself like you know someday I'll be
you know old and unable to climb
mountains and I'll be really glad I have
this experience and if you're thinking
about that while you're on the mountain
like it deepens your experience of the
moment or the fact that we were talking
we
talking about anticipating like you know
they you could be very present in the
moment on your vacation and that's
awesome but isn't it awesome to also
have thought about it for six months
ahead of time and gotten some of the
closure as well I really don't think
this is a paradox at all I mean I think
what we're getting at when we say we
need to you know be in the moment and
enjoy the moment is that often our
brains do go elsewhere in unproductive
ways when we are in something that we
are truly enjoying so for instance if
you are on the mountaintop you don't
really need to be thinking about did I
pay my electric bill because there is
nothing you can do about that at the
moment so it's not very helpful to think
about so you know maybe you could just
sort of in terms of being in the moment
put-put your thoughts on the you know
scenery you're taking in and the
experience and think about the present
and future as relates to that don't
think about all the other things in life
that you could be doing at that
particular moment there's a really funny
Family Guy scene where Peter finally
gets blasted off into space Peter's out
in space and he's observing the wonder
of the earth something that probably
less than less than a thousand people
had seen the Earth from a way a way
outside of itself and he's there looking
at things and this really mindful music
comes on and then very slowly his phone
rises up from the bottom of the screen
and he start he starts watching funny
cat videos on YouTube yeah yeah I mean
human nature right like I think that's
what we're talking about of you know
trying to be in the moment but you know
if he'd thought about in that moment
like what I've looked forward to this
for so long and I'm finally getting to
do this or once I'll and I will look
back on this experience and be happy I
did it you know that those are more
productive thoughts for taking you
elsewhere yeah I totally agree
another example Matt Fraser CrossFit
Games champion for the last few years
potentially the best CrossFit athlete on
the planet ever someone asked him why do
you continue to work as hard as you do
what's your motivation to do all the
things that you do and he said when I'm
old I want to have the best memories
that I possibly can and I'm like if you
use that as your like canary in the
coalmine
for decision making like is this gonna
make the sickest memory that I can in
the future because again remembering the
the present moment is transient but the
future is forever like there's literally
no better guiding principle that I can
think of for when it comes to making
decisions yeah
well then I'd say you know it's
interesting I've oh gosh when I was read
this book once that talks about you know
when you like children for instance and
you're deciding about your family you
make the decision in kind of as you're
going into what is the really hardest
time of children so namely like going
through pregnancy and then when they're
newborns and toddlers and it's really
hard but like they won't be like that
forever like at some point they're gonna
be you know visiting you if their family
is that Thanksgiving we have in the u.s.
here you know use for holidays in
general and it'd be like the question
more to ask is how many people do you
want around your Thanksgiving table when
you're sixty versus how hard is it to
take care of a toddler right yeah but
you know you you have to take yourself
out of the immediate difficulty and and
sort of take the long-term view yeah so
a lot of as many of the listeners may do
I think that I have a I tend to
discriminate towards male authors I tend
to just naturally be attracted towards
that I don't know whether it's a back of
my mind tribal thing whether it's
because I somehow feel that they're
going to get me more or whatever it
might be but a lot of the examples that
you used in off the clock were to do
with family and I'm 31 year old single
guy my business partner is his mrs.
literally within two days he's ready to
pop with a second so I mean she's like a
globe at the moment she's she's gone
home and she's huge but she's she's
absolutely fantastic but yet to see what
for from someone who hasn't had a family
yet to see just how big of a commitment
and a responsibility is and the fact
that you still you're still able to get
[ __ ] done
honestly it's because you spoke with
quite a high amount of fidelity about
exactly what what your day consists of
this one's got to be dropped off it
football then we got to pick this one up
from lacrosse then there's a dance class
then there's a diss then there's odd now
I've got to get home because the
babysitter on them and you just think
like the fact that I or anybody else who
doesn't have those sort of commitments
those family commitments which you can't
turn up late to the kit collecting the
kid from lacrosse or getting them to ice
hockey I think is one of the examples
the wait yeah stop spinning I mean okay
yeah I mean there's a big problem big
things happen like when that happens and
then it just for me having always read
from a much more solitary kind of
personal meritocracy approach to what
I'm doing with my life I just realized I
was like I try and add three kids get
thirty one quite happily there'll be a
lot of men out there who were trying to
run a business like I am with a couple
of side projects and then add three kids
on top and I'm like what am i
complaining about complaining about
fewer productivity books written by
women and I think some of that is that
it's been a space that has historically
been handled from the angle of you do
your thing and you know you're talking
about maybe your time at work and how
you're productive accomplishing certain
things and the home front to sort of
treat it as someone else's domain right
like it's not your thing or you know
even if you do have a family somebody
else's is dealing with that and I don't
think that's the reality for many men
now in any case so you know maybe forty
years ago but I certainly most the men I
know if by the time they do have
families it's it's not somebody else's
deal it's their deal and there's also
women who might like to know how to
manage their time and would like to see
themselves reflected in the literature
as well and so I try to write from a
perspective that you know men or women
could read but it is the perspective of
people who you know your personal life
isn't an afterthought and it's not
a complete you know free and easy
whatever there are responsibilities
within it whether it's that you have
children whether you have other family
members you're caring for or whether
you're deeply involved in your community
and ways you need to meet your
responsibilities to that and you know
honestly I think that that's what time
is really all about that it's not just
you know oh I can when I am done with
work then I kick back my feet and relax
and there's nothing else I need to think
about I think we really are full people
and so my approach to time is doing all
of it I agree I think as well especially
with the hustle and grind mentality that
is pretty sort of pervasive at the
moment guys I garyvee that the sort of
push that kind of always on business
mentality a lot of people adhere to or
think that they need to adhere to it's
like right well I'm going to become more
productive at work so that when I
finished work I can fit some more work
in you you're totally right and to the
listeners at home they'll have heard me
use this example before but I use a the
six minute diary which is a journaling
morning at night three minutes on the
morning three minutes on an evening and
I use that every single day and that
although I haven't done my time
management experiment yet and I'm going
to actually get me and some of the
co-hosts if I can get them to do I'm
gonna get them to to come along with me
into any of the listeners that want to
do as well if you want to give me a
message we'll try and organize it a week
and we'll try and go through from a week
and we'll do all together but that
sounds great that sounds cool I will
give you I'll try and fire you over some
of the stats at the end yeah one of the
guys I'm talking about is a chartered
accountant so his spreadsheet will have
it'll be color coded with V animated gif
yeah they'll be also to stuff but yeah
this this hustle and grind mentality and
we kind of people getting after it
making more time to then get more work
done and what I realized when I was
doing my end of the day reflection which
is three three great things that happen
today
never once in that did I say like I got
2,000 likes on a photo on Instagram or I
wasted an hour scrolling through Twitter
or I
didn't complete my work with as much
virtue or as expedited as hi classes I
could have done all the things that I
found myself reflecting on that I really
valued which presumably would be the
things that were top of the list to make
a memory from they were all connections
with other people or like I had a
message from it from a listener who said
that they absolutely loved the most
recent podcast episode and they've
decided to go sober for six months we
pushed the bright neon on the book yeah
or someone said that they had started
reading a book that we recommended and
they they spent the best afternoon in
Portugal on a holiday or something like
that or whatever it might have been I
had a brief conversation and a coffee
with someone at the gym like all of
those things were things that figured
highly on what I was doing through the
day and by using that over time before I
read off the clock over time I started
to use the things which were appearing
as three great things that happen to me
today
to then guide me as I go forward I'm
like look if it doesn't feature on one
of the great things yeah sure enough
maybe my my commute to work like isn't
Israeli gonna feature on my great things
that I do but maybe one day if I keep on
listening to cool podcasts or listening
to good audiobooks or ringing people
while I'm in the car ringing people like
maybe one day I could actually convert
that journey to Oh caught up with mum
like I had a really cool chat with mom
while she was out with the dogs or
whatever it might be but yeah I think
using that guiding principle is what
were the things that I did today that I
really enjoyed I should probably look at
doing more of those and then compare
with as you say when hopefully people
begin to track their time the link to
the beautiful excel sheet will be in the
show notes below of course when people
compare it with that it's like did
scroll through Instagram for three by
30-minute sessions like didn't do much
for you now so are there any other tools
or any other approaches or concepts that
you think that people should be mindful
of when they're talking about looking at
that time
well something you just said is that so
many of your best moments
to do with your relationship with others
and I actually found that as well in my
time dari projects that for off the
clock and I had 900 busy people track
their time for a day and then answer
questions about how they felt about
their time I found that the people with
the most abundant perspective on it on
time spent the most time interacting
with friends and family and and so
everyone had roughly the same amount of
leisure time I mean most people work
somewhere between 7 and 9 hours on
Monday because that's what people with
full-time jobs do people generally slept
somewhere between 7 & 8 hours overnight
because again that's what normal people
do so then what do you do with the other
time that's actually more discretionary
and so we talked about some people
having little adventures on a Monday
night but you know spending more of that
time interacting with people in real
life whether that's family members or
friends or colleagues or anything like
that is so much more memorable and more
pleasant than interacting with people
virtually or not even interacting with
people right like watching television or
something like that so the people who
had the most abundant time perspective
storage scores spent more of their
leisure time with friends and family the
people with the lowest scores spent a
higher proportion of their leisure time
watching television and I mean it was
the same chunk of time I mean they had
they watch more television than the
people with high temper ception scores
so it's not like they had the people
with the high scores had tons more time
it's just what you choose to do with the
time that you have control of influences
how you feel about time in general why
do you think that is do you think that's
neurological that were built to have
connections with people yeah I mean I
think it you know it feels good right
like I mean why wouldn't we enjoy
spending time with with people that we
feel close to and it's hard to
substitute for that sense that other
people love us and esteem us and you
know the television doesn't do that like
I mean it's it's entertaining sure but
it doesn't give that back and in the
same sense time spent with other people
tends to be more memorable you know it's
just more engaging in general as the
conversation is in person but the thing
is obviously it takes work to do that
like it takes no work to watch
it takes no work to scroll around on
social media whereas it definitely takes
work to decide to get together with two
friends and go do something and so we
tend not to do the thing with friends
because it takes effort you know why
should fun take effort and and so that
trips people up but a life of effortless
fun is not memorable whereas a life of
effortful fun is the present self is a
dick you see it let's sort of pounding
on the ground and screaming like I don't
want to do it I don't want to do it
right whereas you know if you're sort of
step back and say well handle it the
same way like you know we'll be calm and
firm and sort of you know maybe offer
choices I don't know like you know well
we could we could you know do this first
when we go to the Art Museum where we
could do this first when we go to the
Art Museum right but just handle it that
way like it like a calm teacher or
parent would do and recognize that it's
it's you know the equivalent of a
two-year-old pounding on the floor it's
not something you actually need to take
seriously I agree as you saying that I'm
drawn to remember John Peterson's real
treat yourself as if you are someone you
are responsible for helping and he says
that you can literally make deals with
yourself like that and I've tried to now
it's like right okay that I really do
not want to do all of the dishes I don't
have a dishwasher my business partner
saves my kitchens like Basra because
it's because I don't have it was like
what are we going back are we going back
to the Stone Age he was like once every
couple of days there's like you know 20
minutes of washing up and I'm like look
but if you do the washing up after that
we can have a coffee we can have like a
nice coffee we do that and it is bizarre
to make these deals with yourself but I
think especially as you've mentioned
before Daniel Kahneman's work there is
there is a negotiating between a number
of different systems inside of yourself
that you need to make yeah yeah and and
you can do that I mean because yeah
you'll enjoy having the coffee at the
end of it and you know sometimes it's
just about getting over the the
reticence and that ability to do
something to focus on your future self
is of course really the height of
maturity and discipline and it's hard I
mean obviously it's hard or everyone
would do it
but as much as you can get to that place
then you realize how much power you have
over your life and your ability to make
your life very good has the tracking of
your time and looking at the things that
you value through the day has that
influenced your goal-setting or how you
do your more long-term thinking what
we've talked about is quite short term
at least in terms of tactics how about
looking at longer term stuff have you
found that that's been affected at all
well I definitely think about how can I
make my time memorable I would say that
I put more thought into vacations
precisely because that and not just
vacations but like on a given weekend
like what sort of adventure can we have
this weekend I'm more inclined to think
that through to spend some time during
the week consciously thinking about the
weekend so the weekend is not this
afterthought to the week like oh I'm
tired I don't know we'll do what we do
but to say well actually this is a big
chunk of time and I don't want to have
it disappear into nothingness like what
could we do that would be a fun
adventure on the weekend that's
something that will be memorable but you
know it's also certain things like being
more conscious of using my Low Energy
downtime to read verses other things
that I could be doing everyone has some
quantity of this time that you know it's
it's leisure time and the but it's
either late at night or it's you know
well you've done something else you
don't have a ton of energy as you are
going into this leisure event and so
that's when we tend to watch TV we surf
the web you know just sort of do
whatever because it's easy but if you
think about what else could I do at that
time and so reading is an obvious
suggestion but of course if you don't
have a good book you're not gonna read
you're gonna do something else so being
more careful about getting good books I
when I track my time for the first year
I
been telling myself I had no time to
read because you know I was very busy
like it was when my my kids were at
their youngest like I you know I was
busy okay and no time to read and then I
tracked my time and I saw I was reading
almost an hour a day but it was like
nothing it was like magazines it was
random articles online and I was like
well that's stupid like I can read I
could have read war and peace ten times
in this chunk of hours that I've spent
reading like yet another article on how
air popped popcorn is a great low
calorie snack like I don't need to read
that article ever again so now I make
sure to have good books and if I have
lots of good books I will read them and
if I'm really involved in a book I'll
start finding more ways to put time into
it whereas if I don't have the book I
want so that's that's a big change I
made yeah for sure
again to draw a lot of what we've been
talking about recently on the podcast
together
James clear you don't rise to the level
of Eagles you fall to the level of your
systems if you don't have the system in
place that allows you to read the book
if you haven't spent sixty pounds on
your Kindle or you haven't bought the
new paperback or gone to the library or
whatever it might be you you you can't
do the thing and as we've identified the
present self as you've said it's kind of
a petulant child but I've said he's a
dick and they naturally you go to the
through the path of least resistance
which tends to be the scrolling the
Netflix or whatever but it's a subtle
point it's a really important one that
you've made there about the fact that
you can't it can't always be right let's
let's go do salsa it's like yeah it's
it's 11 o'clock on a Friday night like
I'm not gonna there's no app can't go do
salsa but what can I do with this time
at this lower energy state yes then
still will give me this sense of
satisfaction and again the plan that the
talk about committing to plans for the
weekend reminds me of something from
deep work which is ease Cal says
strategizing is easy but execution is
hard and it's because execution involves
a genuine commitment people can talk
about plans yeah it was like well you
know what we should do we should totally
go do that yeah we should totally go do
that it's like no one books it no books
it and I want to think back to some of
the plans that me and my buddies have
been making that we've been saying that
we're going to go and
like a meditation retreat for three
years like you just needed to book a
meditation if you want to do it I mean
maybe you don't want to do it which I
mean that there's always the possibility
that plans without commitments on the
calendar are sort of just a nice way of
interacting with other people some
people enjoy you know talking of
possibility in a way that isn't about
actually doing it just sort of it's nice
in the abstract to do meditation retreat
but if you actually want to do something
then it's gonna take time and where is
that time well you need to identify a
time that you will do it
what is that time if it's not on the
calendar it isn't there it's not gonna
happen yeah in fact I totally agree
um so as a final question I wondered
whether or not there was any people he
met that really surprised you with how
much they could fit into their day if
there was some people who were like full
time as mum combined with running like
CEO of a company or if there was some
people who would just think you were
super surprised at their capacity to
expand their days oh yeah well so one of
my initial interviews many many years
ago like you know 12 years ago as we're
writing my first time management book I
had interviewed somebody about a totally
you know different thing related to her
business at one point and in you know
offhand she mentioned her like six
children and I was like oh well that's
interesting you know what I was you know
very new in the parenting journey so
she's like oh my god how do you do that
and so I called her back to interview
her about that and and that aspect of it
so she was running a successful small
business with many people on the payroll
and you know so she had the stuff she
was managing for that then also raising
her family and you know I can ask her
well like you know spill your secrets
like oh the world would love to know and
she the way she put it something I've
said it like in all my speeches sense
and I couldn't put it most of my books
but there she said you know everything I
do is my choice and rather than say I
don't have time to do X Y or Z she'd say
I don't do X Y or Z because it's not a
priority
the
I don't have time really means it's not
a priority and if you think about it
that is more accurate language I mean
people will tell you they don't have
time to floss it's not true they don't
want to floss like you know using this
language reminds us that time is a
choice and it's not that there won't be
consequences to making different choices
I mean of course there's gonna be
consequences but over the long run we
have this power to fill our lives with
the things that we deserve to be there
and so if you just substitute this
language every time you find yourself
saying I don't have time I don't have
time I'm too busy I don't have time okay
it's not a priority and and see how that
feels and if it's true it's true and
like you should just own that truth I
mean it may be something that sounds
wonderful I don't know you know saving
historic buildings and you know
volunteering with Pepys or I don't know
I mean they're wonderful things in the
abstract but if you're not doing them
it's because it's not a priority to you
and that is fine there may be other
things that are priorities to you right
now
but if something is a priority for you
then you owe it to yourself to figure
out how you can put at least some of
that into your life and I'm not saying
it's gonna be you know forty hours a
week but could you put twenty minutes a
week related to this into your life I
think it's pretty difficult to say you
couldn't find 20 minutes somewhere in
the course of the week and if you get 20
minutes awesome see how it goes didn't
know and if it didn't work why not like
what was the logistics did you not
really want to do it was something else
that was a problem that you need to do
it anyway you get 20 okay hello Anne can
we do 30 can we do 40 um and you know if
you if you get to the point where you
are spending an hour a day on things
that really truly feel meaningful to you
I think that's the tilting point it
doesn't have to be forty hours a week it
can be one hour a day of something that
is genuinely meaningful and enjoyable to
you like the rest of life will feel
completely different I totally agree
there's a david deida the way of the
superior man he has I think it's rule
number five or six and he says what you
consider to be a highest calling in life
can you dedicate 30 minutes a day to it
do it now and it's totally the same
thing like what are the things that you
actually value carve out time to do them
and if you can't carve out the time
stops
the most important things in your hockey
because they're evidently not yeah Laura
today's been fantastic I wanted to ask
if there were any more resources I know
there's a TED talk that you kept on
citing in the book who was that even me
I'm self-referential here she is now I
think about this um lady who when I gave
my TED talk she was also at the
conference and so I was very taken with
her talk and she was the one who's done
a lot of she's a memory researcher and
she's a lot of the information in off
the clock on time and memory comes from
hearing her talk and then interviewing
her later about that she's the one who's
really shown that time and memory are so
related and that wanting more time is
about wanting more memories and and in
fact we can make memories sharper after
the fact she's done some fascinating
research with that that it turns out
memories aren't just set when you do
them like there are things you can do
afterwards that make the memory sharper
that make it deeper that make it more
likely you'll recall it later what are
those things well um I mean in her case
what are the way she showed this is that
she shocked people like gave them
electric shocks so this is sort of
tangential here but say she she'd show
you pictures of like shapes or show you
pictures of animals and at first you're
just looking at whatever and then she
shocks you every time you see a shape
and amazingly enough the after one fact
you know if you were shocked when you
saw shapes you remember the shapes
better than the animals but in fact you
also remember the shapes from the
earlier run like when you weren't being
shocked better than you did back and
said this matters like this matters and
I needed to remember that so it recalled
it better than the stuff that it turns
out your brain learned it didn't need to
know let's me you're not going to shock
yourself no looking at photos looking at
photos of a trip afterwards talking with
the people who were there one thing gosh
he told me this story which I found so
funny but I love it so when she was in
college she went on a European trip and
one of her you know fellow travelers
played the same song over and over again
she's like this is horrible
torturous but he's like no no no for the
rest of your life every time you hear
the song you will think of this summer
and it's true yeah and you know because
it conjures up the feelings alongside
the the memories as well and so there
things you can do like that creating
artifacts that you can then tap into in
the future yeah I think he used the
example that you've got a treasure trove
of like receipts and different bits and
pieces and then you can just have a
little look through that and it gives
you a reminder I'm sure there'll be
people who will know that particular
smells or whatever it might be
definitely all of those can conjure
stuff up fantastic so we've got a
Leila's TED talk which will be linked in
the show notes below is there anything
else you've got some resources on your
website yeah sure I mean I hope people
will come visit my website Laura Vander
cam comm you can learn about all my
books there i blog usually a couple
times a week you can read about my
podcasts I have one that's every weekday
morning called before breakfast it's
five minutes just a short productivity
tip every morning so give that a listen
and start your day with a bit of a jolt
in the arm nice every weekday morning
that is a serious commitment but then
again if it matters you'll make time
yeah exactly
my job doesn't seem like that
theoretically at least I'm getting paid
for it well Laura it's been fantastic
today linked to off the clock your
social media your website and all the
stuff we've talked about today will be
in the show notes below thank you so
much for your time
[Music]